je vais le téléphoner à la télé parce
que je travaille à la télé je vais leur
téléphoner pour leur dire comment
comment ils accueillent les touristes
ici vous le prenez comme ça voilà alors
votre portable voilà non non non voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez mis votre temps à l'endroit où
il faut pas alors
[Rires]
non non non non
interdit les portables sur la plage et
oui sur la place pourquoi ça fait chier
tout le monde
vous êtes en train de téléphoner vous
venez le récupérer au commissariat
[Musique]
pour récupérer ou pas
voilà comme ça on l'entend plus
je vais le téléphoner à la télé parce
que je travaille à la télé je vais leur
téléphoner pour leur dire comment
comment ils accueillent les touristes
ici
[Musique]
je peux pas travailler demain
aussi je vais le dire à la télé
[Musique]
un agent de force de l'ordre alors je je
je
ne le
monsieur non je ne m'excuse monsieur ça
veut rien dire
[Musique]
ça fait des ça fait des inter des
interférences sur le sur le système de
navigation et donc comme il y a marée
basse vous voyez vous vous venez au
commissariat alors
non non pas de suite moi je finis ma
ronde je finis à 19h
que des enfants
du casino qui roulent
comme ça alors hop voilà maintenant vous
pouvez le déclarer
je vous ai dit de partir vous venez
jeter notre portable à l'eau
[Musique]
vous allez le déclarer noyer
j'ai toutes mes cartes commerciales qui
sont avec ce table non c'est pas un
jetable
et il savait pas nager
[Musique]
et voici votre ami ne pas regarder par
la fenêtre
ah oui c'est bon
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît vous sortez du véhicule
police nationale
pour handicapé là ah d'accord ça va tout
de suite en plus
à éviter ce que vous faites là pourquoi
si vous voulez que je sorte le carnet de
table à moi de dans pas longtemps ça va
ça va se couler encore plus
je peux la finir
vous pouvez finir
immédiatement dans 5 minutes
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
ils veulent pas qu'on se mette tout nu
dans le bois ah non non
que je peux me mettre tout nu ici avec
vous on craint rien
non non
donc je me mets un petit coup de rouge à
lèvres puis c'est bon non c'est un mec
c'est différent
[Musique]
le mono ça passe encore mais n'importe
comment une femme à poil ou un gasi à
poil c'est clair c'est
exhibition sexuelle ça rigole pas avant
nous on a peut-être des collègues qui
vont là-bas
c'est pour les vacances
c'est c'est super
ouais bien
moi
non non c'est moi qui est intéressé
c'est pas pour le vendre c'est pour les
mettre sur les cartes postales de la
Croix Valmer
je vais en faire une comme ça c'est
rigolo
on met des petites légendes maintenant
ici on est mieux qu'au bureau
pourquoi c'est sympa c'est rigolo
[Musique]
si parce que pour ces photos là il faut
que ce soit un peu un peu chaud quoi
prenez une pause plus encore
voilà
bon maintenant badigeonnez-vous de
chocolat
bouge pas
[Musique]
c'est pour demain